tick tock deal
was approved by trump however it's a
little tricky here
oracle and walmart will reportedly take
a combined 20 stake in a new company
tick tock global
bike dance tick tocks chinese owner and
the main character in this drama is
expected to keep 80
but american interests control 40
percent of bhaitans
so the new company will have majority
u.s ownership per trump administration
but trump's original demand for baidance
was to sell tick tocks
u.s operations over national security
concerns isn't happening which leaves
some critics asking
what was the point of all this after all
oracle and walmart are happy oracle will
get a big boost to its cloud business
which will
which has lag rivals like amazon walmart
will flex its e-commerce muscles to tic
tocs 100 million dollar monthly active
users
the order to ban tick tocks off the
app store has been delayed so there's a
bunch of different things i have here
but adam i'll go with you first so first
question i have is what the hell is
going on here
so trump comes out there says he's gonna
shut down tick tock
people are shuffling they don't know
what to do all of a sudden oracle steps
in then the two days later
the deal's off he's gonna ban all the
downloads people are rushing like crazy
to download the app millions and
millions and millions of downloads over
the weekend
we were in la i had to film a little
segment breaking news what's going on
now walmart's stepping in i'm looking
just for a little bit of clarity here
the story keeps changing keeps changing
i will say respect to trump for making
some deal happen we don't know what the
deal is at this point
clearly we're not fans of china clearly
they're using some sort of espionage and
you know i don't i doubt that they're
spying on just random tick tock dancers
anyone who's in the government shouldn't
be uh on tick-tock
busting out their dances but it's the
story keeps changing does it not here's
the best part of this story now when you
go to tik tok
you know what's gonna appear on screen
an old person in a blue vest
welcoming you just like at walmart
welcome to tick tock
can i point you into any direction you
know this is strictly data
isn't it everything about this and
that's the one thing we don't really
understand
we don't understand how countries and
how big big companies
just process this data and what they're
using it for but i mean do you think
that walmart
and oracle and these companies were
doing this to help out the united states
at this time of need
i mean now this just opens the door for
them to have access to a brand new
generation
of consumers that they can market to
forever and ever and ever it's a smart
business plan
played by these guys i don't look at it
as they're helping us stop the evil
empire of china
uh by banning them from having tick-tock
and doesn't this require some level of
cooperation
between the us and china we hate each
other how did this even happen
where we could like get control of
twenty percent of this company money
money i i i listen i don't think this
deal is going to go
uh uh i think it's gonna have a lot of
hiccups remember whole
louis vuitton was trying to do their
deal with tiffany's and it was constant
delay delay delay delay delay
i think this could end up being the
ultimate delay delay delay here's why
so trump says yesterday uh if walmart
and tick tock do not have full control
of it i won't approve it
that's what he said yesterday number one
they don't have focus and
there's no way they could no they don't
have full control of it then china says
if they're forced to give up the whole
control of the company
they want to prove it then china china's
going to have a board seat
of the tick tock company ran by america
so if
the original deal i'm going to be on the
opposite side with you
if the original deal was to prevent tick
tock from having
you know how they were saying that tick
tock is watching your phone if you
download tick tock they can
get into your phone i don't know if you
guys remember we spoke about this a few
weeks ago
they could get get into your phone and
see all the other things that you have
on your app they can only get your
password that was the original story
that was the original story that was the
so if that's the original story trump
hasn't yet
delivered on the promise the promise was
that we are not going to let china
control tick tock
and china's still going to have control
over tick tock so i don't see this deal
fulfilling the prophecy that was said a
few months back i think it's like a
headline that sounds great but what
about the years and years of data
and the control of your phone that they
already have i mean look that hasn't
gone away they're not making them erase
it
it's one of those things that on the
surface is gonna if you're not
into this and sophisticated enough to
understand all the nuances of this it
sounds great and you think hey we stuck
it to china
but really i don't think we did and i
just look at walmart i mean they are not
doing this
for the greater good they're doing it
for their own benefit and that's it
yeah i'm wondering why microsoft
did it wasn't more competitive in the in
the bidding because initially this was
going to be a microsoft play
maybe they thought they couldn't get
enough control maybe they didn't think
there was enough in it for them
i think microsoft works actually the
least two companies that you would think
doing this deal is
walmart and oracle if you would have
said a month ago
who do you think is going to end up
buying tick tock who the hell would have
said walmart and oracle honestly
who would have said walmart and orders
that's a combo you never would have
probably that's like mike tyson mary and
britney spears i mean
who that's that's a weird hit me baby
i mean that just doesn't make any sense
to me to see these guys deciding to buy
tick-tock yeah now how much do they have
to work together
walmart and oracle i mean are they
partners in this thing where they're
going to control board seats and have
executives like merging i mean how weird
that's odd
there was like an addendum to the story
where trump was demanding
5 billion for a re-education
of american uh history did you hear that
part of the story
no like you said i i think this story is
going to be
constantly evolving constantly changing
it's in the headlines obviously tick
tock is
a super popular app i mean just goes to
show how many
millions of people downloaded over the
weekend because as of sunday it was
gonna
no more downloads were allowed to happen
people were rushing to it like hotcakes
now it's open again it's gonna be until
november 20th it's going to be
probably a weekly story that we're going
to be covering you know why until we get
[Music]
sick